brazil has been a latin american leader
in fighting the coronavirus but it
wasn't always that way the country was
battered by the covert 19 pandemic with
618 000 deaths it's second only to the
united states for the number of
fatalities
now infections in brazil have plummeted
due to high vaccination rates nearly 80
percent of adults have been vaccinated
at least once
but fear remains particularly as the
country prepares for the impact of the
new omicron variant
welcome to your covert 19 special i'm
daniel winter
brazil is ending the year on a high not
of covet cases like some countries but
vaccinations let's take a look now at
how the country faced down mounting
deaths and a president who downplayed
the impact of the virus to become one of
the world's most vaccinated populations
against covet
hardly anyone in the world thought it
possible a year ago the corridor of this
hospital in the brazilian city of toledo
is deserted a lot of the emergency
equipment has been put away in the
storage room this is the result of what
might be brazil's most successful
vaccination drive against covet 19.
we used to have 40 incubated patients
here now we don't have any
and it's very rare for us these days to
have to provide that level of intensive
care
the cases are also much less severe than
before so we can think more carefully
about how best to treat those who are
sick and to give them a better prognosis
made up
it is a far cry from the first half of
2021.
covered casualties peaked in april
reaching more than 4 000 deaths in a 24
hour period
brazil's mega city sao paulo was
averaging between 700 and 800 deaths a
day
today it is the country's poster child
for coronavirus vaccinations with 99 of
adults here having received at least one
shot by november
of course i think people should get
vaccinated and that means everyone
many brazilians are afraid of the virus
and get vaccinated so as not to be
contagious
brazilians believe in vaccines after all
we have been getting vaccinated against
tropical diseases for a long time we
like it
but while brazil may have turned a
corner in fighting the pandemic for now
there is one persistent problem
poverty has been exacerbated ordinary
brazilians are struggling
earlier in the year we met sylvia de
jesus a cook who was supporting three
other adults as the only one in her
family to still have work
albeit just one day a week she used to
work other jobs too but her other
employers let her go for fear of
infection
this pandemic is difficult it's going to
leave all of us starving and that's
apart from all the damage it does to
your health look at this cube
we're all in the same boat
every afternoon sylvia was queuing up
for food donations
since the beginning of the pandemic in
brazil in march last year the residents
association has been distributing
rations
the latest figures show the economy
stagnating and inflation rising food
prices increasing while jobs remain few
and far between
while the worst may be over the pandemic
is still ravaging brazil bringing
poverty and hunger to more and more
people
and let's get more now with fabio layal
a research doctor specializing in
infectious diseases thank you very much
for joining us fabio um what's your
opinion on why brazil has been so quick
to take up the vaccines
thank you for having me here daniel well
i think that and we've known we've known
that for sure for decades that the main
reason for the success in brazil with
vaccination is the public health system
that is universal in brazil so free for
every brazilian and within this system
there has been for decades a very
complex and efficient vaccination system
that has worked to get even to very
remote areas in the country so we
created a culture of vaccination as well
as the infrastructure needed to get to
every brazilian as quick as possible
and so it was that infrastructure which
already existed
that overcame the resistance from the
top of national government would you say
yes especially because this healthcare
system that we have in brazil that is
similar to what has been
a reference in the uk
provides institutional
structure so it's very solid so our
institutions are stronger than any uh
provisory or um temporary government who
will not that might not be supporting
this system as much as needed so
obviously there were several and major
limitations because it's been
underfunded chronically but still it's
in place and working and it has the
population
more than 75 percent of the population
actually uses this system regularly and
it's structured in a way that uh
our agents are community agents that
knock on people's doors and follow the
health situation of the entire family so
they rely on this system the brazilians
rely on this public health system and
that's why vaccination was not
such a new idea or challenging idea
despite all the difficulties that we had
with communication and just goes to show
how important that kind of long-term
investment in education around vaccines
especially around infrastructure how
that really pays off but when we look to
the short term
is it time for brazil now to open up for
new year open up for carnival as some
politicians there are suggesting or is
that just too early
well we are going through a new moment
we are learning as time goes by how to
deal with the pandemic and not only from
the perspective of the virus and disease
but also as a community as a global
society so after two years of going back
and forth with lockdowns and
strict measures
we have to learn how to better handle
the situation because it's a much
different situation from what we had two
years ago as was mentioned in brazil we
have the majority of the population in
major cities like sao paulo and rio over
90
of the adult population is fully
immunized so even if we have a surge of
cases which is likely to happen is
already starting at this point like we
see in europe and north america we
expect that hospitalizations and the
death toll will be very different and a
lot smaller than we had in previous um
waves so hopefully and we are preparing
for that situation we will deal with
mild disease that will um actually
create pressure on the health care
system but not in hospitality
hospitalizations and death tolls
okay and you're mentioning in that the
while factoring in the the omicron
variant and the new wave which could
come from that so that flexibility is
important there as well with dealing
with new variants but i want to move on
to as we saw in the report the fact that
poverty has worsened in brazil what's
the connection in brazil between poverty
and covet
well it's a direct connection as it is i
think worldwide because as we
have to
slow down the economy and all the
activities the social activities those
who are more
vulnerable
have less opportunity
to
earn their
basic
needs and that creates an even bigger
difference between
those who um have more of the funds and
the money from from the country and
those who have less access so this is
creating increasing this difference in
brazil and in many other parts of the
world
all right well it's uh plenty of lessons
to learn from brazil it seems fabio leal
thank you very much for that
thank you
and now it's time for you to ask and for
us to answer here's a viewer question
for our science correspondent derek
williams
[Music]
can vaccines end the pandemic
you know it's interesting to look back
on nearly two years of reporting on this
pandemic and and realize
how much our ways of thinking about some
things
have changed over that period of time
remember
for instance when we all more or less
thought that if we could just manage
to vaccinate 60 to 70 percent of the
world then we'd hit herd immunity and
and soros kov2 would be conquered and
would just sort of magically go away
well
along with vaccine hesitancy in many
places the arrival of new
more highly transmissible variants and
waning vaccine-induced immunity
have kind of put paid to that idea
experts don't talk about
herd immunity much anymore and i think
that's because it's always been pretty
closely associated with the thought that
we'd be able to eradicate covet 19 and
and most scientists no longer believe
that we'll be able to do that
in fact
most think now that the declaration that
the pandemic is finally over when it
comes
that it'll be um less of a bang and kind
of much more of a whimper for most
experts the goal
has stopped being to wipe out the
disease entirely but instead
to manage it as we do others and that's
where vaccines will play a really major
role
though the evidence indicates that
vaccines don't do as much as we'd like
to hinder the transmission of sargos
kobe 2 or to stop infection with the
virus entirely
they do generally prevent the
development of severe symptoms that can
lead to hospitalization and death so
in that sense
vaccines can end the pandemic
not by helping us to wipe out sars covey
2 completely like
the smallpox vaccine wiped out that
pathogen but instead
by protecting enough people well enough
that one day
we'll be able to live with cobit 19 like
we already live with the flu
[Music]